you say you're not a people person that
you always have had trouble with this
idea of being famous and people
recognizing you and looking at you
you've snapped at fans or you've snapped
at people that recognize you because it
feels strange to you is that right well
yeah and I'm sorry for that but you know
when we got in bands we weren't trying
to be famous we were trying to be
anti-establishment and like not mix with
society it was kind of more of a not
really underground I mean we never
really was in it for the fame or the
money we just wanted to it didn't didn't
work that way you know you you did for
fun right so I think it was my
generation we weren't very good with the
it wasn't a celebrity culture yes well
you talk about that because now a people
of course people are obsessed with who's
famous and what is celebrity when you
were starting out how's that working out
for you um when I become famous I'll let
you know when you go out in the street
if people rec you know I think you know
what I like I do like people I think
that's just my nature I like people and
I'm interested in people so I don't have
a problem doesn't feel like a fake thing
but that's personal to me if people come
up and they like my work and they just
want to talk I end up talking to them
and it feels like a real human exchange
that doesn't happen so often huh what's
that when people walk up yeah oh no I
was kidding I get mobbed wherever I go
I'm kind of a god
in Finland well this is a fascinating
story but but you you but you also like
to get out and experience the world in a
real way like you were people some
people thought it was very strange but
you like to ride the bus like you've
written the bus in different cities or
the bus in LA is that right yeah and
people fight you find crazy
I mean I got on the bus one day and for
three days people are saying did you
really get on the bus yes what yeah yeah
am I missing something here yeah and and
but you like it because it's actually an
experience to see people as they are
right because there's a what well it's
also getting somewhere
so they're driving around and dropping
people off
it was just a mobile mixer like people
hanging out chatting yeah I thought it
was like a swingers thing I see these
buses around when I think living in my
gold limo and I'm fascinated by them
there's a salon going on in there
well it seems fascinating no but I've
had when I lived in New York and I would
get on the subway the same people who
always come up to me and say why are you
on the sub right you'd be like because
they take you from point A to point B
and then we would both urinate against
the wall hey thanks for watching please
subscribe to my youtube channel so they
will stop making me shoot these videos
please